today is 4/20 you know yes 4/20 is that
special day of the year when everyone
who smokes pot continues to smoke anyone
who celebrates 4/20 is doing the same
thing today they do the other day's
crazy news and if you saw this last
night Donald Trump hosted a dinner at
the White House that was attended by
Sarah Palin Ted Nugent and Kid Rock yeah
yeah the dinner was interrupted when an
episode of cops broke out literally
shirtless
[Applause]
[Laughter]
get in the car it's true it's a crate
you've seen the photos right through
Sarah Palin visited the White House last
night along with Ted Nugent and Kid Rock
all three express their regrets that
honey booboo couldn't make it
they said the chair for her and
everything the seat he couldn't be there
of course here the big news is Bill
O'Reilly after allegedly sexually
harassing his fellow employees Bill
O'Reilly is leaving Fox News with a
severance worth 25 million dollars so
with that in mind I just like to say to
Andy nice rack
yeah work it little crazy today North
Korean leader Kim jong-un warned that he
might unleash this is a quote a super
mighty preemptive strike a super mighty
preemptive strike when she heard mrs.
Kim jong-un rolled her eyes and said
trust me I wouldn't worry about it
crazy news from sciences scientists have
developed a new kind of robot that is
able to shoot a gun yeah in fact earlier
today I was carjacked by my Roomba I did
that I knew that was bad but I I just
lived I was carjacked by my Roomba
please that was for me can't I have one
I know it's not good
yeah this is weird Major League Baseball
was planning to have a game of Thrones
theme night at stadiums across the
country at baseball stadiums Game of
Thrones
instead of bobbleheads fans will receive
actual severed heads you'll get a head
when you come in it's bleeding
we have to go boy you know those are
gonna end up on the field I know and
it's a timeout outfielder gets that
severed head off the field a man is
suing grinder a man is suing grinder
because over 1,000 men showed up at his
place of business demanding sex yes
though in fairness the man does work at
Al's house of crawlers and anonymous gay
sex and I think that's
- I was carjacked by my Roomba Wow
you